it's Monday and I realize it's been a
while since I caught up with Andy you
know oh yeah you know you're right we
haven't really talked in a while yeah so
I thought I'd take some time to catch up
with my close personal friend mr. Andy
Richter yeah doesn't that sound great
Andy I think so too
let's do it hey Eddie how was your
weekend
oh it was it was great thanks for asking
Conan let's see on Friday the whole
family we went out for a Korean barbecue
Saturday I hung out with my friend Matt
and then on Sunday my daughter had a
soccer game soccer daughter man that's
fascinating stuff Andy how's your
daughter Anna
her name's Olivia she's doing fine ah
that's really great to hear and II can't
believe she's almost 11 11 yeah 11 years
old man time sure does fly it sure does
so how was your weekend Conan that's
pretty good Friday I went to a charity
event Saturday we drove up to Santa
Barbara and on Sunday we went to a flea
market Wow
all of those things sound interesting a
truly great weekend man I gotta tell you
it really was and how is your wife right
wife how is she doing she's great she's
great Andy thanks for asking
you know Andy we should get together one
of these weekends huh that's a great
idea you know what I am gonna put it in
my calendar right now guess what Andy
I'm gonna do the same
there we go all right in the books yep
see you then this has been Conan and
Andy's obligatory minute catcher
you
you